[音楽]
今日は皆さんはじめ社長の屈筋教室で
陽子さんチラッ
[音楽]
まあ俺氏はが全く是正しないですよなんで今日はねまぁたまに本当に年に12回ほど
しかせナイフもしてるんですけど肇社長クッキングしようと思います今日は記事から
ちゃんと
パスタを作っていこうと思いますはい昔一回料理どうだっつって朝ゆでて食ったら
料理じゃねーじゃんって叩かれてちょっと怖いんですけども今日はねちょっと記事から
しっかりつくっていくことです
良いというものはこちら協力小麦粉今いこオリーブオイルでお城た真央
釣れた
お前の俺方が料理すると思うか bar 回あるの記事のパスタを知り2に討ち入りて
非常ちゃんと便利章取りますシュレッダーですこれが知ってるか
[音楽]
うっうーるー4言わない pop っっ
ティッシュアウディするとペシュでなんでシュリッターにかけた分までくっついて
るっていうで術絶対加減ないくっつくだって一緒安剛
全然壁姉や今日の始めちゃいまーこのシュレッダーを使ってパスタを作ろうとですはい
作り方は全く分かりませんクックパッと見ましょう
一覧こんなは合わせてふるいにかけひとつかみは打ち子様にとってうちの子や孫とに
貴重にこれを作ります
全然他のことを作りうちちょっと撮ってあげてる
ちょっつー見せますできる気がしてまずは粉を合わせて封印にかけますそれすごく強力
こと
薄力粉を合わせてふるいにかけるようにねこういうことでしょ
いわゆる in ジャケでもいいかつでしょよしにかつい考えてしまう今なおショタば
パイライトな素敵よねぇ適当でこれ狂いに掛けるってことは交渉
これでこの人たぶん混ぜ合わせるということです
[音楽]
ん
なぜあいましたこれは打ち粉用にとっておきます
くぼみをつくれって書いてある中央にくぼみを作りますそんな雲見に卵塩オリーブ油を
入れます
卵は3つです
よし by これこれまもなくまだまだまだまだ詰まったと言えば以下の1パウダーっ
てまた下がるとしていますどうなっちまう
引越し舞ちゃん美味しいぞやるからこっち作ろうきつかっ
で塩とオリーブオイルを加えてフォークで球を持ってきます着火去ってきた花オリーブ
オイル
どれぐらい冷媒が全然わからんでも適当でいいようですはぁっはぁっはぁっ
馬をロボットはかき混ぜます
ブーブーって
ていました
持っています
会議はこんな感じですどうでしょうかどうでしょうかつともは金子から4横で始めです
いやー悪いなぁほいってるは多分だけどぽいも粉が大事な音なんだろう俺のくらいので
くれないと分かんだよね
こんな稼げないっていうのか超えて外側から内側に行こうねっとよくわかんないです
けど
って人でずっとだよこれがなめらかになるまでやり
ましてっん
刑事が出来ましたたぶんこのでいいと思いますよ
ここから生地をボウルに入れて振れた金をかぶせて30分ほど寝かします
これは投資ます超えないんで生地を4等分してで台湾にしてパスタマシンでてます
楽しいこれがシュレッダーととかそうかここでシュレッターですねこれ結構いい線いっ
てると思うけど
これは1個ずつ伸ばしてパスと場所に打ち方ってここで打ち込んでパスタを作ります
います余震が怖いです5ラップはちょっとになさっ
おっ
はあれ伸ばしたりぬというので待って鳴らなくね何この門前ばないかんって揺れさ z
よなぁ
入れされてをさっき一方的に行くのと分
は自転車来たぞ来たぞ
一つ一つは著者何も入ってもらいましたん
言えるよって坊
ています
[音楽]
あれ
姉2抹茶詰まっちゃったけれどの
一応何度の面にはなりました1回目に詰まっちゃったんだよなんか無理感があるんだ
けどねか
シュレッダーの間がパスタで埋まっちゃったちゃんと多分ちゃんと伸ばせなかったから
こんなことを言ったじゃん今度はちょっと伸ばしてみましょう
うーんちょうどしましたこれでいけなかったら任せてもいいんだけど
おかしくねちょっとクって何で関連のに全然動かないんだけど
ターミナル希望の光ガスこのパスに入ってんだ
なんでなんでなんだよんなんでできないパッサよ俺はショックっていう
ねーむれーできるできてますなぁこれだけですだめだ完全に完全に壊れちゃった
韓国を
赫赫後数分極薄よ
をに横で作っています
ん
はいという意味でナポリタンでされぼなーらじゃねーか
カルボナーラですずっと連れでしくったから全然疲れなかったっけ今日の夜ご飯はこれ
だけです
それったか壊れちゃったけどまっ作れる立っちゃっ作れたんでちょっと
なんでもないし真面目呑山日からやるどんな様はをどんどんですまずはいけない人たち
がマジでガチの手作りとから楽しみたくなりますいただきます
[音楽]
ん
あ
意外と梅は
[音楽]
打っています
持っています